[Music]
they are the two computer whiz kids who
changed the world as we know it
larry and sergey always had this kind of
irreverence as part of their attitude
which is what
made them so creative these two founders
really think of themselves as noblemen
they think that what they're doing
is good for the world
larry page and sergey brin were the kind
of guys who kept bill gates up at night
journalist ken aletta i said mr gates
what is your nightmare and i thought he
would say apple or
netscape or oracle and he said i'll tell
you what i worry about
i worry about some guy in a garage
inventing a new technology
microsoft has never thought about well
in 98
two guys were in a garage and the hand
lettered sign and it said google
worldwide headquarters
in an industry where innovation is just
part of the job description
larry page and sergey brin have become
virtual masters of the universe of
information gathering
what we don't know we google 629
000 results wow and all this time i
thought googling yourself meant the
other thing
not anymore silicon valley is littered
with startups that have stalled out
why these two computer science geeks
succeeded may have a lot to do with the
nearly parallel lives they led before
creating together one of the world's
largest and most powerful companies
brynn and page respectfully declined to
participate in this program
sergey brin was born in the soviet union
in 1973
his parents were mathematicians and
jewish which limited their career
opportunities
mark malseed is the co-author of the
google story
so sergey's father went to a conference
in warsaw
met a whole bunch of colleagues from the
west saw what life was like outside the
soviet union came back
sat the family down and said we have to
leave
his parents brought with them a sense of
purpose they instilled in their son
it boiled down to a simple message don't
come back with a b
don't come back with the second place
award make it first
always and sergey internalized this and
it did form a core part of his
personality
like brynn larry page was born in 1973
his family lived in michigan and his
father was the first person in his
family
to get a college degree both of his
parents were in similar fields as brins
they were second generation computer
science which at that time
was very unusual because computer
science was really only developing as a
field
in the 60s and here both of their
parents
were advanced degrees they see
themselves as on a mission
and that mission it really does spring
from their biographies in 2009
paige shared that mission with the
graduating class at the university of
michigan
you know what it's like to wake up in
the middle of the night with a vivid
dream
and you know how if you don't have a
pencil and pad by the bed it will be
completely gone by the next morning i
had one of those dreams when i was 23.
when i suddenly woke up i was thinking
what if we could download the whole web
and just keep the links and i grabbed a
pen and started writing
soon after i told my advisor terry
winograd
it would take a couple of weeks for me
to download the web he nodded
knowingly fully aware it would take much
longer
but wise enough not to tell me
stanford professor and engineering
consultant to google
terry winograd larry just thinks of ways
of doing things that you might not
expect
sergey was a lot like larry he also was
someone who
really wanted to think outside the box
to say if that sounds like it's
impossible
let's try it it was 1995 at stanford
university
when the headstrong overachievers first
met
one of their stanford professors used to
say well the difference between the two
of them
was that sergey would just burst into my
office without asking
larry would knock and then burst in in
the 90s
searching the internet was rudimentary
hit or miss
often returning results that were
useless
and the process was very slow
then you typed in your query you did
something else while you waited for it
to get the results then you went back
and looked at the results and
most of them were completely irrelevant
paige and brynn pushed for something
better
sergey's big interest was in taking all
the pages on the world wide web
and trying to make sense of it trying to
find patterns they started to do
a record of backlinks they called them
page noticed that behind every web page
there were hundreds
or even thousands of other pages that
linked to it
[Music]
it was a eureka moment that would change
the so-called
information age then they realized that
that list of backlinks could be used for
ranking if you have more backlinks it
showed you a better page
[Music]
if a lot of other websites linked to a
web page that probably meant
users thought it was good
the genius was recognizing that this
kind of algorithm could give you the
kind of results that mattered the most
to searchers
paige and brynn had their secret formula
now
it needed a name the guys were looking
for a great name that was going to
capture the grandiose vision that they
had
and hit upon this giant number
one with a hundred zeros after it
commonly known as google
g-o-o-g-o-n they discovered it was owned
they said you know what let's put a
friendlier spelling on it
on september 15 1997 they registered
google as a website
and paige and brynn dropped out of their
phd programs
to focus on attracting funding for their
young company
it wouldn't be easy investors like ram
sharam
were skeptical there were five search
engines at the time
and so i said maybe any one of them
might be interested in the technology
the world didn't need a sixth search
engine
[Music]
google just didn't fit into the
conventional wisdom of what a website
should do
which was to keep users from migrating
to another page
google did the unthinkable it helped
users explore the wider web
larry page and sergey brin had a
different attitude they said we don't
want a portal
we want to get the search results to
them in a split second
so one sunday morning larry and sergey
were sitting on the porch of a stanford
professor friend of theirs
and andy bechdelsheim one of the
founders of sun microsystems
pulls up in his sports car walks up gets
about a 10 minute demo
says this is fantastic this is the next
big big thing and writes a check on the
spot for a hundred thousand dollars made
out to google
inc steven levy is senior writer of
wired magazine
this is the way things work in silicon
valley you know it it sounds astounding
that someone would just write a hundred
thousand dollar check and get you going
but you have to realize
that there was a hidden pedigree to this
they were at stanford their professors
had done this before
this is a pretty good bet we might lose
100 000 but
we could win big there and at the time
we had no company at all
and in fact we couldn't cash the check
just by the way with no legal documents
you know none of that stuff
and even though they had the seed money
they still needed much more cash
no one was buying into google they went
back
to ramsharam they found three other
investors and together
we raised enough money to get them off
the ground
enough money was one million dollars
including 250 thousand dollars from jeff
bezos of amazon.com
paige and brynn incorporated google on
september 4th 1998
and they moved into one of those storied
garages in menlo park
they attracted the attention of two
well-known silicon valley venture
capitalists
michael moritz of sequoia capital and
john doerr of kleiner perkins
both wanted an exclusive deal brennan
page
said no deal they had the presence of
mine at their tender asia in their
mid-20s then
to say we won't take money from only one
venture capitalist
we want to assure that neither one of
them has control so we're going to split
it
in june of 1999 google issued its first
press release announcing the investment
25 million dollars brennan page now
needed to hire
first-rate engineers people who would
meet their exacting standards
chris sacca is a former googler it was
one of the most
intense hiring processes of any company
in the world i had somewhere
between 12 and 15 interviews over just a
couple days
they created a headquarters they called
the googleplex
offering employee services like free
food and child
care and developed the informal company
motto of
don't be evil but google
still wasn't making money larry would
come in and i would say well
how are you going to make money from
this google co-founders larry page and
sergey brin
had created a new search engine but had
yet to find a way
to turn it into profit they didn't like
the idea of using
advertising to cash in at first they
thought advertising was grubby
commercial kind of unseemly they're
famously sparse homepage was originally
designed by sergey brin
unlike rivals yahoo and aol paige and
brynn refused to clutter their homepage
with ads
we won't take any ads on the homepage
because we think to build
of trust we want to not feel like we're
bogging them down
with advertisements yet no ads at all
meant no revenue
page and brin had to accept advertising
as their only option
there were search engines in the early
days which when you went to a page the
first few things
which looked just like regular search
results happened to be things that the
sponsors of those had paid the search
engine to put there
and they said that's not good for users
i don't want the things that somebody
else wants me to see i want the things
that i want to see
then they found a compromise they could
live with they
invented a new way of targeting text ads
triggered by
search requests instead of distracting
pop-ups
or flashing ads these small ads were
placed
above and next to search results it's
familiar now
but revolutionary back then they called
it
google adwords businesses big and small
could take control of their advertising
dollars by purchasing ads
key to certain words david thacker was a
project manager on adwords
advertisers love the system because they
only pay when someone actually clicks on
their ad
for many advertisers it's the most
efficient form of marketing they ever
have
for businesses it was the holy grail a
direct connection to their best
customers
with a massive new revenue source google
exploded
by september of 2000 it had indexed a
billion urls
and was available in 15 languages
still with all of google's success few
people outside silicon valley
knew who had created it sergey brin
went on to tell the truth
and fooled the judges sergey brin
please stand up
[Applause]
but media moguls knew exactly who they
were
barry diller was one of the first
traditional media executives to visit
google guys
larry is sitting there with his pda his
little handheld
device and he's looking down and doing
his email and he says larry
please i'm talking to you can we just
converse
and he says i can do both very dilla
says no you can't do both choose
he says i choose this
with tremendous growth came other
challenging issues for the search giant
google
the venture capitalists behind the
company michael moritz and john doerr
were pressuring its co-founders to hire
a ceo
they were resistant but they didn't want
to say you know we can do it
but they thought they could do it they
went through 12 13 14 interviews
they didn't like any of the people they
they saw they visited steve jobs just to
meet him because he was a hero of theirs
and they said to
john dora after the meeting why can't he
be our ceo
john doerr introduced paige and brynn to
eric schmidt
a businessman with an engineering
background
you've just hired eric schmidt he's come
over to run google
yes what's the idea behind that
i mean you guys couldn't run it yourself
uh parental supervision
to be honest you know eric is the
grown-up in the room i mean he's
he's in his mid-50s not mid-30s he's got
a lot of experience
he's more of a diplomat than they are
and that's needed in dealing with the
traditional media world which they
increasingly bump me up against
by the end of 2001 eric schmidt was
google ceo
page became president of products and
brynn the president of technology
the two founders still shared an office
they have a mind meld
they anticipate each other's words they
back each other up there's no
sense of tension between them it's one
of the great strengths
of that company with eric schmidt in
place
google kept up its spectacular growth
while its rivals
slowly faded away
the search engine linked to 3 billion
web pages and forged a partnership with
aol
which brought them 34 million new
customers you have this incredibly
profitable company how are you going to
get into the next level how are you
going to
provide the kind of capital growth that
they needed
the solution it was time for google to
go public
being unconventional they decided that
they were going to hold an ipo
unlike any that wall street had ever
seen they were going to set the price
via an
auction to determine and try to extract
the greatest
value from the stock
the stock price on august 19 2004
closed at just over 100 a share making
the company worth more than
23 billion the two founders
became billionaires
soon the company expanded with google
maps
google news and google earth
their idealism and bold ideas had built
their reputation
but the company was stumbling with their
free email service
gmail was a great product that was
really poorly launched
when users saw ads pop up that were
directly related to their personal
emails
alarms went off when people first saw
these ads they were shocked because they
thought
how could these ads be so targeted you
know i'm reading this
this email about uh you know my friend's
vacation to hawaii i'm getting
ads about hawaii is somebody snooping
into my email
the concern around gmail launched a much
deeper fundamental argument
about privacy and trust do you know how
google's using all the information it
collects on you all of the web searches
that i've done
for years and years all of the emails
that i've done
potentially information about health
records information about the books that
i'm looking at
information about where i'm going
because i'm typing it into google maps
in a sense they're the big brother that
we've been talking about all these years
the ultimate big brother was about to
put their don't be evil philosophy to
the test
in 2006 google reached an agreement with
china for access to their 400 million
web users with one condition
they censor search results of banned
topics
for bryn son of russian immigrants it
was a troubling decision
at google's friday meeting sergey spoke
with passion about growing up in the
soviet union and how
his parents literally escaped the soviet
union to come to america and what that
meant to him
and that dialogue happened including
everybody they wanted to hear from all
the employees there
sergey swallowed hard but they all said
at google
this is the biggest consumer market in
the world we have to be here
google agreed to chinese demands i know
there was a lot of controversy
surrounding that and we had to self
censor a fair amount but we were
actually able to
censor less and less and our local
competitors there also censored less and
less
so i feel like our entry
made a big difference but
things started going downhill
google discovered a cyber attack on
their systems
the more troubling thing to me is that
we discovered the motivation
which we believed to be to gain access
to gmail accounts
in particular for chinese human rights
activists
google pulled the plug and redirected
users to an unfiltered site in hong kong
that isn't subject to censorship leave
britney spears
alone right now youtube began as a place
for people to share home videos
it soon grew into one of the world's top
search engines
by july 2006 users were uploading 65 000
videos a day
and google wanted in they went out and
acquired youtube for 1.65 billion
dollars in google stock
youtube founders chad hurley and steve
chen were thrilled
today we have some exciting news for you
we've been acquired by google
yeah thanks in 2006
google ceo eric schmidt acknowledged
that to stay competitive
the company also had to enter the world
of mobile phones
in fact a year earlier they had quietly
bought another startup
android a small company with software
for cell phones
there's so many more mobile phones than
personal computers as people do more and
more searches on mobile phones
it should eventually balance out again
this would be many years
it didn't take years apple's phenomenal
success with the iphone in 2007
set a collision course between the two
companies
months later brennan paige announced
their android operating system
would run on a variety of mobile phones
their longtime idol steve jobs slammed
google for entering the phone business
and accused them of trying to kill the
iphone
at the google developer conference in
may of 2010
google's vice president of engineering
tore into apple
if google did not act we faced a
draconian future
a future where one man one company
one device one carrier would be our only
choice
that's a future we don't want
and google is battling with another
giant in the tech world
they bump up against microsoft in so
many ways they have a browser
chrome microsoft has internet explorer
google also acquired companies
that dealt with online versions of word
processing software and spreadsheets
things that directly go after
microsoft's jugular with their office
product
microsoft fired back with its own search
engine
bing which debuted in spring of 2009.
can i ask what you make of bing do you
like it
um i think uh you a bing user
uh oh yeah no no i i use i use all
search engines out there
uh i think that what bing has reminded
us uh
uh is that the search is a very
competitive market
bing ironically offered google
protection by letting them dodge
accusations of being a monopoly
bill gates said this is the company that
is closest
to us as a competitor they are just as
hungry
and as ruthless he didn't use that word
but i am
as we are there is a danger they make a
lot of enemies it's a blind spot
because these two founders
really think of themselves as noblemen
they think that what they're doing
is good for the world they've always
enjoyed
feeling like the underdog feeling like
the evil empire was microsoft
and now they've discovered that and some
people think
they're the evil empire their own slogan
do no evil
was suddenly being used against them
google's quest on the road to organize
the world's information
took a new turn call it a detour with an
ambitious feature they called
street view an attempt to photograph
every neighborhood
on the planet
it would eventually include ordinary
images from main street
to extraordinary views of antarctica
but the effort also took private user
information from unsecured wi-fi
locations
many people felt their privacy had been
compromised
google acknowledged the mistake and
agreed to destroy data
the company known for search was
struggling to diversify
and was facing an aggressive new
challenger mark zuckerberg
facebook's one billion users spend more
time on the social network
posting valuable information that is
invisible to google's search engine
information that all advertisers chase
so far google's efforts at social
networking have failed
but its founders are keenly aware that
as users habits on the web change
google will have to make a lot more
friends
in january 2011 in a startling silicon
valley shakeup
eric schmidt announced that google was
simplifying its management structure
and that larry page was ready to lead
and would take over from him
as ceo co-founder sergey brin
will focus on new products schmidt
tweeted
day-to-day adult supervision no longer
needed
in 14 years google grew from startup
to technology giant hitting 50 billion
dollars in revenue in 2012.
in the space of a year larry page and
sergey brin both got married
page married stanford bioinformatics phd
lucinda southworth in december 2007 on
richard branson's island
branson was also his best man
brynn married biotech specialist ann
wojitsky
in the bahamas with his partner larry
page standing up for him
they both have two children
[Music]
google.org its philanthropic arm has
contributed over 100 million dollars to
various organizations from clean energy
to global health
larry page and sergey brin have changed
the way we get information
it's been a a great experience for me to
see them grow
over the last 12 years that i've known
them i feel extremely
proud of what they've accomplished larry
and sergey always had this kind of
irreverence as part of their attitude
which is what
made them so creative it's great i think
google attracts people who care
who care about users who care about
their fellow human
who care about the planet and just can't
sit still
they built a company that absolutely
changed the world
[Applause]
[Music]
you